haha the Joe Rogan experience I was
talking with my buddies and I'm I've
been having a really good time with um
my son making stuff he said man I know
this may sound crazy but just Coronas
[ __ ] he said you and your son look back
one day you're gonna be like hey Dad
remember when we made that on slingshot
doing it when a corona was out yeah you
know I'm saying it's like and it's like
you know the memories are gonna be there
all type of ways yeah you're building
memories that you wouldn't have
ordinarily built yep as long as you're
alive and as long as you're healthy it's
just it's I think the positive side of
this you can always look at the negative
side but the positive side is look how
many people are complying look how many
people are doing the right thing right
that's a lot of people and they're doing
the right thing because they care about
their loved one but didn't flee they
care about your loved ones and people
aren't complaining as much people not
day like that's what I mean some people
are hurt and financially a lot of people
losing their businesses they're hurting
but the amount of strike he'll do it the
amount that you see in the streets as
far as like riots and protests it's
non-existent people are understanding
we're all [ __ ] this is like we didn't
see it coming
we all got a deal I just hope this makes
people realize that all that pull them
up by their bootstraps stuff like people
love to think that that's how people
should be you know you should just pull
yourself up by your bootstraps go out
there and [ __ ] make something for
yourself that's all true
you definitely should go out there and
try to accomplish some goals but there's
gonna be times in our lives as a
community where some [ __ ] goes down it's
not anybody's fault but they need help
and that's when we have to evaluate what
our taxes go to because if our taxes
don't go to some form of excellent very
accessible health care and making that
more widespread then you're basically
saying you don't really care about
people's health and their survival as
much as you care about money now if
we're gonna commit to that kind of a
culture after something like this well
we're insane we're not learning anything
we should learn something from this no
we can learn from this is like we could
health-wise we were not prepared whether
it's through hospital bills
I see use ventilators social distancing
protocols whatever the [ __ ] it was we
weren't prepared for something like this
but now that we are we should all go hey
yeah you know what man
no one should not have the money to pay
for treatment for this so what do we do
what do we do Joe what do we do what do
we change the way we look at our
services it sounds like you said we've
got a change thinking period change
thinking but also change what what our
money should go to our money's got to go
to that it's got to go to that but
that's very important for everybody when
people get sick it spreads to all of us
now we also we don't want ever to know
anyone that you love that's gonna die
because they can't get health care
that's available for people that have
money that we've got to stop that just
like we stop with fire department Fire
Department goes to a house when it's on
fire because not just to that house they
don't want to spread through the whole
city let go well that's the same thing
with health care if someone's really
sick they don't help you and you got
coronavirus you spread it to everybody
else right you don't get the health care
so it and you you're contagious it's
almost like a fire in a lot of ways like
a viral fire but aren't we living in a
system where everybody is qualified to
have health care we should be we should
so what is it what is covered California
what the [ __ ] is that all about
I don't know man I don't I mean if you
think about how much money gets spent on
things right whether it's computers
whether it's cars whether it's houses
whether it's with other things that
people buy how much of a percentage of
that if you could escalate it just a
little bit and all of that money goes
into just health care not just taxes
worth no one's accountable you don't
know where the [ __ ] it's gonna go what
if everybody's dollar cost a dollar five
just an added five cents for most things
you buy up to a certain point all that
money goes straight to health care
wouldn't you be willing to pay instead
of a dollar a dollar five or something
if you knew that five cents is gonna go
towards health care that's you know what
as a business person deficit may mean a
lot to me as a business you're right
it might that's what I said that's it
might be for I can't know I look at no
that darlin darlin five that's the only
five cents now if you talk about that
being billions and millions then up to I
said up to a certain point to a certain
amount of money but I mean after a while
of you yeah it seems like it would be
better for everybody
and it would be better for us to not
worry about what happens if you get sick
because you don't know if you're gonna
be able to pay for it sometimes people
get hit with crazy medical bills after
their you know an unexpected injury all
right unexpected disease time in the
hospital they got a huge bill they can't
[ __ ] pay it's real common that no
bankrupt because of that kind of [ __ ]
[Applause]